foreign
[Music]
I'd like to report a crime that hasn't
happened yet have you seen the movie
Back to the Future basically I'm living
that movie right now which is how I know
there's gonna be a murder tonight
hey time travel movies never make any
sense
[Music]
Halloween candy
hard this time of year is for us your
friends were murdered 35 years ago it's
not 1987 anymore stay safe honey I love
you
[Music]
oh
my God
what the [__]
excuse me what year is it 1987. oh my
God I know the 80s are almost over and I
haven't even tried Coke yet
I don't know
oh my God Mom
[__] off and die Jesus mom
um Mamacita
for my birthday [__]
creepiest cabin in the middle of [__]
nowhere what's the big deal there is a
murderer on the loose and you drove us
into the woods
I forgot to bring vodka
you have seven and a half hours until
you're stuck here forever
[Music]
happens
the machines kill us all no they more
just rip apart the fabric of our society
via dance videos on Tick Tock face dance
against us
now Waters form just so you know I don't
do [__] you pee out of that thing
think maybe if she did do [__] still
be alive
yeah let's not make that the lesson
[Music]
80s weed sucks this is just dirt look at
all these Twigs yeah I could give you a
gummy this big and it's 100 times more
weed than this
[Music]
foreign